nein
[Musik]
dieter bohlen
wahrscheinlich wird das so jemals
passiert ja leute hätte kommt ein video
von dem ich nicht gedacht hätte dass ich
es aufnehmen würde aber ich muss euch an
dieser stelle leider sagen es sind
inzwischen gravierende dinge passiert
und ich sehe mich genötigt dieses video
jetzt hier doch zu machen die rede ist
geht eigentlich nicht den kopf frei
dazwischen wieder hier sitzen aber
glaubt mir wir müssen und wir werden
spaß dabei haben denn die unendliche
geschichte mit kein master geht weiter
es sind seit meinem letzten video was
bestimmt wieder drei vier fünf sechs
wochen her ist wieder neue werbespots
von master angekommen also die werden
nicht müde uns zu bombardieren die sache
ist die ich regelmäßig um eine instanz
rein und da sehe ich immer wieder wie
wir die neuen call master clip geschickt
und mir so sagt was dann reagiert man
darauf so wir können es nicht ertragen
und dann leute klar will ich mal nicht
so sein wir haben heute einige neue
clips wir haben daniela katzenberger am
start können die frank rost am start und
wir haben
dieter bohlen anstatt labbadia wohl
macht jetzt auch werbung für köln
mastercard aber cool wenn ich vielleicht
aufhören könntet euch ränder
irgendwelche menschen zu graben für
werbung kleine besser das ist so krank
ist wie das so krank schlecht gemacht
warum warum hört mir keiner zu sagen
dieses videos hin mache ich hab das
gefühl nicht vor allem niemand bei call
master ist also ihr werdet vielleicht
sehen heute wir fangen an muhammad mit
dem prostep der ist abrufbar unter aller
sau steigern uns dann ganz am ende werde
ich euch den dieter bohlen glück zeigen
und ja dann ist es komplett vorbei durch
schicken ja so gute idee
ok wo stopp stopp stopp stopp stopp also
fette klippan gut was haben wir hier wir
sind in der kammer sap scheinbar ok und
jetzt hat er einen niedlichen armor an
irgendeine frau geschenkt als irgendein
mädchen aber ich weiß es nicht wieder
irgendein in der diese werbung
geschrieben oder die texte für die
werbung geschrieben erstens da wo
eigentlich nachricht oder zumindest auf
englisch message stehen sollte steht
einfach massage also juli hat eine
massage geschickt kommuniziert man
allerdings in massagen oder ganz davon
abgesehen dass palmas jetzt haben wir
das neue kinder ist und man sich seine
dates seine girls oder typen über treuen
master ja besorgt und dann natürlich
eine andere massage verschickt wir
kennen es alle schreibt wir ja wow danke
bin am weg welcher weg julia und warum
bist du am weg was soll jetzt dein date
damit anfangen dass du am weg bist
welcher weg feldweg oder wo immer die
box thule höher ist ein wirklicher das
einfach keinen bock sich so treffe ja
bin am weg selbst heraus welcher weg
also wir haben ungefähr so drei vier
fünf sekunden und sache angeschaut und
köln komplett verkackt ok also müssen
wir nicht einmal reden komplett drei
geschossen
ja natürlich sollte wird es allemal hat
sich dann verabredet also ich sehe es ja
meine statistiken dass ein großteil
mädels meine videos schauen und ich
meine mails immer ganz ehrlich
miteinander also wenn euch jemand einen
niedlichen armor auf call massa schickt
dann julia
und kaputt
er war soldat
ja wissen was mit diesen clips mit
zerstört so dass diese situation die so
niemals passieren würden es kann mir
kein mensch erzählen dass man eine
hübsche frau über ein online spiel
kennen lernen kann zumindest nicht
solange noch beide arme und beine hat
aber kein wasser würde zumindest glauben
lassen dass das in ihrem spiel möglich
ist man muss einfach nur niedlich
schicken
dann kommt eine massage zurück von julia
oder voneinander mädchen indem sie
anderen sagen dass sie am weg sind was
immer noch nur ortsangabe ist mit der
ich nichts anfangen kann sowieso denn
neben dem baum bis gleich aber machen
weiter mit dem clip von daniela
katzenberger
ok also der clip beginnt so dass daniela
katzenberger natürlich da einfach so
steht und sich einfach ein abschlag weiß
einfach so geisteskrank viel spaß macht
köln masse zu spielen wir kennen das
gefühl alle sehr echte darstellung muss
man sagen ihr könnt mit sicherheit alle
die situation wo er einfach in eurem
wohnzimmer steht ohne erkenntnissen
grund ich steht einfach da und lacht
werden händisch gespielt
[Musik]
und dann zeigt sich relativ eindeutig zu
meinen augen die absolute sünden befreit
von dem spiel also ihr kompletter
freundeskreis oder gefühlt alle menschen
die kölner überhaupt jemals gespielt hat
in ihrem leben greifen sie an auf ein
okay also es eine konzertierte aktion
die dafür abgestimmten ausgerichtet ist
daniela katzenberger auszulöschen
endspiel also diese ganzen leute
verbünden sich gegen sie greifen sie an
und dann was macht sie
[Musik]
greift einfach wieder zurück an geiles
spiel
wo ist der sinn darin warum sollte man
in diesem spiel überhaupt irgendwas
machen wenn sieben leute sich gegen
einen verbünden ok und kraft in der
überzahl sind und einen fertig machen
wollen man kann ihn danach einfach
zurück an greifen soll
wo ist der sinn dahinter also darum
sollte man denn überhaupt irgendjemand
angreifen wenn man so eine hardcore
gamerinnen wie daniela katzenberger
nicht sieben zu eins aus diesem spiel
eliminieren kann sondern die retter dann
direkt zurück angreift und scheinbar
einen dann platt macht wusste sind also
versteht ihr was ich meine leute so
warum sollte ich dieses spiel spiel so
gibt es überhaupt eine belohnung dafür
dass man sich darin anstrengend oder
kanal wenn ich mich mit 1000 sollten
zusammentun und irgendwie angreife
greift einfach zurück und tausend andere
macht uns bleibt weil so funktioniert
einfach übrigens hier auch mein
gesichtsausdruck gemein direkt sagen wir
irgendeine werbung nahe legen will
das ist doch bitte kein master spielen
sollte aber jetzt sollte wenn es lange
genug auf den werden starten wir den
clip mit rein es ist soweit es ist
tatsächlich passiert kein master hat
dieter bohlen gekauft für ihre werbung
okay ich dachte es war vorbei sein dann
kommen sie auch dieter bohlen um die
ecke
[Musik]
naja ok ok wo fangen wir an ein paar
dinge die mich direkt daran stören erste
sache dieter bohlen einer der
wahrscheinlich prominentesten menschen
in deutschland keine ahnung x-fache
millionär läuft natürlich in irgendein
café rein und spricht irgendwelche
fremden du liest an ob sie ihn gerade in
köln master angriffen haben also sowieso
diese geschichte jetzt schon mal
komplett absurd was gibt überhaupt keine
intro es ist einfach dieter bohlen das
gesicht von dsds und ich glaube wirklich
einer der bekanntesten deutschen soll
läuft einfach irgendein café rein und
quatschen pärchen an
auch das wird niemals in unserem leben
im leben von call master oder im leben
unserer galaxie jemals passieren und
dann leute frei nachdem köln meister
werde prinzip wir geben millionen für
stars in unserer werbung aus aber die
storyline für unsere werbung schreibt
der einarmige passiert einfach wieder
exakt das gleiche wie es auch schon ein
bisschen daniela katzenberger werbung
war wie schon in der englischen werbung
war und es ist immer das gleiche auch
hier fragt wieder irgendjemand zwei
leute ob sie sein dorf oder ihr dorf
angegriffen haben und eine person sagt
nein eine person sei klar dass bitte was
neues aus der kasse
[Musik]
dieter bohlen
wahrscheinlich wird das so jemals
passiert egal wie absurd ist das denn
entweder wir angreifen okay wir haben
hier das handy max julia oder dieter
bohlen
[Musik]
das würde absurde kacke habe sondern
schon passieren wird er herkommt
[Musik]
also leute ohne witz dass man könnte es
nicht unrealistisch gemacht und ist
einfach so ein pärchen ich denke mal so
ende 20 mittel 30 so die sehen aus die
menschen die ich spreche ein bisschen
bildung haben so sie können aus ihrem
leben was macht was mache ich
stattdessen locken natürlich kein master
und noch wahrscheinlicher greifen
natürlich in colmar dieter bohlen dann
weil man kennt deutschland prominenz
sitzt natürlich im servicefall immer nur
ein paar meter von einem entfernt und
sagt es gleich die handyspiele gute gute
story line gute texte die euch der
überlegt hat kein master beziehungsweise
die du dir überlegt hast geehrter
einarmiger schimpanse im keller von kein
master vorher was ich nicht verstehe so
schauen wir auf den screen so dasteht
drache okay ganz oben steht die rache
rache für was in dem video ist keine
rede davon dass dieter bohlen die vorher
angegriffen hat oder wie wofür wollte
euch rechten für dsds oder wie habe
sondern schon passieren wird er zwar
herkommt was soll da schon passieren
würde etwa herkommen und dann 88 und
witz da kommt wirklich vorbei hier geht
mir bei konz ich glaube euerdorf nicht
mehr ein
also das ist wirklich die absurdeste
scheiße die jemals gesehen habe was als
sie was mit diesem kit positiv auffällt
ist dass er zumindest keine
rechtschreibfehler drinnen sind so also
keiner sagt der schild am weg oder
verschicken der massage oder so was ich
glaube das machen sie dabei den
trendbruch somit nur bei den pros haben
sie den inder der die texte schreibt
ganz ehrlich leute ich fühle mich
mittlerweile von deutschland als land so
krass verraten so es würde mich nicht
wundern wenn nächste woche einfach
angela merkel im placement für paul
master macht wirklich wundern aber ist
es noch mal an der stelle leute
hoffentlich kommt kein master nächste
woche oder auch in keiner späteren woche
mit angela merkel oder jerome bord
hängen toni kroos oder luke mockridge um
die ecke und setzt die ganze herford
bitte kommen was da dass das einfach ok
danke ich hab jetzt vertretenen personen
vor gestalten das video hier oben könnt
ihr meine kappe nehmen euch dieses video
gefallen hat leute danke fürs zuschauen
danke fürs gemeinsame über call master
lästern das war es so weit von mir ich
küsse raum macht's gut